You always have to run the background process
Whether it's syncing with the server to get the latest content
Still computing data for your application
However, running the background process poses a problem for the operating system.
Even 20 apps have issued very important background work requests
The application the user is using still needs to run smoothly.
Android Oreo introduces a completely different way
To let people rethink the issue of background services
Some apps can't run anywhere in the background
This includes apps that start running via implicit broadcasts.
And apps that are opening multiple services in the background
Let me take a look at the affected APIs.
The orientation API has also been affected, but now I will not talk about it.
You can check out the documentation link attached to this article to find out
More details about orientation updates
These changes apply to all apps designed for Android O
Even if your app is not designed for Android O
Users can still enable these restrictions
So you need to pay attention to these changes anyway.
The first background behavior change is reflected in the service aspect
Calling the service from the background call will result in an IllegalStateException
This change does not affect services that are open when the app is visible or in the foreground.
Will not affect the binding service
In the following cases, the application will be considered to exist in the foreground.
When your app moves from the foreground to the background
There is a short grace period before the service is closed
When the service is shut down, it is like issuing the stopSelf command itself.
These changes will affect all services
So is the IntentService affected?
um, yes
Is the PendingIntent service affected?
Not affected at creation but will be affected when sent
Even the services you open in the background and want to push to the front desk will be affected.
The good news is that there are still several ways to save your service.
Unless your app is an alarm clock app
Otherwise, in 90% of the cases, your best choice is
Replace your background service with a scheduled job
Although you can no longer open the service in the background.
But the scheduling job can do the job for you in the background.
This requires the framework to consider all scheduling operations and their constraints
And decide when and when to run which scheduled job
There are several solutions available for scheduling jobs
Depending on the needs of your application
I have attached the relevant text below to explain the different trade-offs.
But if you want to hear my advice,
I suggest you use Firebase JobDispatcher
And the new Job IntentService
Job IntentService can easily replace IntentService
The following is a temporary service whitelist.
Here are a few special cases
The app will be temporarily put into the whitelist here.
Take effect in a short time as if it were in the foreground
If you want to trigger work when server data changes
Please consider on your server and application
Deploy Firebase Cloud Messaging
If using high priority FCM messages
You will receive the message immediately
Even if the system is sleeping at the time
You can also easily use the service whitelist
It allows you to open the service
Make the app look like it’s in the foreground
If it is a normal priority FCM message
Then the message will be delivered when the user opens the device screen
Or served in the sleep maintenance window
But you can't be included in the whitelist of startup services.
If your app receives both high priority and normal priority information
One way is to try to start the service
If it fails for any reason
Enable the fallback scenario: start the scheduled job
If the user wants to interact with or monitor the service
You can create a front desk service
Front desk service has continuous on-screen notifications
This tells the user that the service is running.
Various timing and navigation applications are common
Application examples for efficiently calling services
The problem is that the way to "open the front-end service from the background" is not working now.
You need to use the new API to open the front desk service.
The procedure is to use the new startForegroundService method first.
The background service created by this method must be pushed to the foreground immediately.
Create a notification inside the service
Your front desk service notification should always have a lower or higher importance
So users can see them
It can't have a medium importance
The final step is to have the service use the startForeground command.
And the notification you just created yourself push yourself to the front
If you need PendingIntent to open the front desk service
You can use the new getForegroundService method of PendingIntent
Then push it into the front desk in the same way.
If the above methods are not suitable for you
You can consider postponing your homework
Until your app appears in the foreground
If you want to test your application under new constraints
I also attached the link below with the adb command.
They can make the app run in the background
And enforce background restrictions for your app.
Ok, now let's talk about the limitations of implicit broadcast receivers.
Statically settled receiver that is answering implicit broadcasts
Will not receive these broadcasts
Implicit broadcast has no target feature attribute
The stationary broadcast receiver is defined in AndroidManifest
Before Android Oreo
Implicit broadcasts trigger everything in the Manifest that listens to it
This leads to memory jitter under research constraints
Because at this time a broadcast will trigger
a lot of different components in many applications
You can replace the static implicit broadcast receiver like this
There are a few exceptions to note, so be sure to check this list first.
If the broadcast is on this list, it will not be affected.
It will continue to operate normally
This list contains locale changes, plugged into headphones, etc.
See the attached link below for complete documentation.
If your broadcast is not on this exception list
You may be able to replace it with homework.
The job can be activated by
Some of these situations have been added to Android O.
In particular, the content provider observer can trigger multiple jobs.
Used to respond to a wide variety of environments
For example, when a user saves a new photo on their phone
If some of your apps are already running when the broadcast is ready
You can switch to the dynamic broadcast receiver
This means removing your broadcast receiver code from the manifest
You can then create, register, or unregister at runtime.
Just like what I am doing now
Although these scenarios are more focused on background processing
But its benefits are that can be experienced by the front-end users.
That means less circumventing fewer crashes
For users who cannot use expensive, high-speed hardware
The benefits it brings are particularly impressive
I just talked about a lot of strategies and API changes.
If your app is affected
If you want to learn more and want to start to understand the code examples,
Please refer to the attached document